يمين يشير الى هذا العاجل روتز عن مصادر
روسيه مقتل ثلاثه واصابه 13 في انفجار
ذخيره بمقاطعه بالقرود قرب الحدود مع
اوكرانيا امين ماذا في التفاصيل
[تصفيق]
جلال قبل نحو ساعتين كانت هيئه الطوارئ
بمقاطعه بيلجراد قد قالت لي وقالت طاسه
روسيه ان 10 جنود جرحوا جراء انفجار في
مبنى لدار الثقافه في احدى البلدات التي
تقع الى شمال من مدينه بلجراد وهي في
الحقيقه مدينه بعيدا نسبيا على الحدود
الاوكرانيا نتحدث عن نحو 100 كلم لكنها لم
تشر همم بشكل واضح الى اسباب هذا الانفجار
الذي تراه حريق كما سبق وقلت الان ربما
تاكدت همم او تاكد مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص جرى
هذا الانفجار لكن مصادر اعلاميه هنا في
روسيا تتحدث
عسكري باحدى
ال ال الوحدات العسكريه فجر قنبله يدويه
ما ادى الى ااا هذا العدد من الخسائر
وطبعا لم تشر ايضا الى خلفيات هذا الحديث
لماذا هذا القائد العسكري فجر القنبله
اليدويه في حين كانت هناك معلومات على ان
همم هذا المركز الثقافي كان ياوي عددا من
العسكريين المجندين الروس الذين لربما في
طريقهم الى المشاركه في العمليات العسكريه
في اوكرانيا